Speaker 1: I want to talk a little bit today
about incels now.
This is often mentioned jokingly, but this
is really a serious and important thing.
It's often mentioned casually, you know, a
lot of terrorism, a lot of domestic terrorist
acts at their core are the results of incels.
Now you might not know what an incel is.
Incel is short for involuntarily celibate,
involuntarily celibate incel.
I hope that makes sense.
And what it refers to is an incel is someone
who would like to be in a sexual relationship,
but they are unable to get into one because
they either can't find someone to be in such
a relationship with, or they're too shy to
try or whatever.
So they're celibate, but not voluntarily involuntarily.
Now, whether this is funny or not, it's actually
a real source of concern about the radicalizing
effect of incel circumstances.
And there's a new Secret Service report exactly
about this.
And I've mentioned this in the past many times.
How many of these incidents that we are seeing
are a combination of radical political radicalization
and the frustrations of involuntary celibacy?
Of course, of course.
Of course.
Never saying.
That anybody who can't find a date is going
to go out and commit violence or act of terror,
overwhelmingly almost none of the people that
are involuntarily celibate are going to go
out and commit acts of violence.
But is it a factor among some of those that
do a very interesting CBS right up?
New Secret Service report details growing
incel terrorism threat The federal government
on Tuesday today released a study on the growing
terrorism threat from men who call themselves
anti-feminist or involuntarily celibate and
draw motivation for violence from their inability
to develop relationships with women.
Tick almost exclusively.
These are heterosexual men who would like
a relationship with a woman and are unable
to find one.
Since 2014, attacks inspired by the incel
movement and spanning the U.S. and Canada
have left dozens dead.
Early intervention and behavioral threat assessments
could be the difference between life and death
for women targeted by the growing ideology,
according to the 26 page report.
The report concluded that while quote, There
is no one profile of an individual who plans
or executes an act of targeted violence, investigators
must consider potential targets when seeking
to thwart attacks, as suspects routinely quote
explore multiple targets during the planning
process before making their final decision.
The U.S. Secret Service's National Threat
Assessment Center took a deep dove into a
serious series of red flags, predating a shooting
at a yoga studio in Florida to determine how
early intervention could have saved lives.
In the case of 40 year old gunman Scott Paul,
barely there were countless warning signs.
The man who opened fire inside hot yoga Tallahassee,
killing two women and injuring four before
committing suicide, had previously been fired
from multiple teaching jobs barred from bars
in apartment buildings.
And once authored a 70000 word revenge fantasy
about a boy turned serial killer.
There is a so putting that particular story
aside, the whole point here is an analysis
of the idea that there are people motivated
to carry out violence by their inability to
either develop or maintain a relationship
with women.
Now, the report mentions, and it's important
to consider the origins of anti-feminist and
incel movements vary, and they're not always
the exact same thing.
So there are people who are radicalized into
extreme anti-feminist ideology, not necessarily
by their personal inability to form a relationship
with a woman, but some are.
And then along those same lines, not all incels
are anti-feminist.
Some are just in cells and they're fine with
feminism, but they just can't develop relationships
with women.
For what may be a number of different reasons
now, Jordan Peterson has actually talked about
this before.
Jordan Peterson at one point talked about
something called enforced monogamy, and he
says that's not literally like you force people.
You don't forcibly pair women off with men
to prevent them from being in cells.
But here's what Jordan Peterson had to say
about it.
Speaker 2: Okay, so the question is, what
do you mean by enforced monogamy?
Well, we can start by what I don't mean.
I don't mean taking innocent women at gunpoint
and handing them over to useless men.
Speaker 1: That's good.
OK, that's a good thing, which is
Speaker 2: essentially the accusation.
You know, it was really interesting to watch
that unfold.
What I meant was that monogamy as a as something
that's socially valued is it appears to be
essentially a human universal
Speaker 1: that does not actually seem to
be true.
I mean it that that may well be true in modern
society, but historically, that's that's not
really been the case.
Speaker 2: Doesn't mean that human beings
are universally monogamous because obviously
we're not.
We can be serially monogamous and some people
are players and have multiple partners and
all of that.
But there's a strong proclivity across known
societies to tilt towards monogamy, and the
enforcement is social norms.
It's like to think about it, and I can't believe
that I even have to say this your son just
gets married and he comes home and he says,
Guess what, dad, I've been screwing around
and what do you do?
You had him on the head when you say, Hey,
good work.
That's that's my young man, right?
Well, no, you're not happy about that.
And he doesn't tell you because he knows you're
not going to be happy about it.
And that's enforced monogamy.
Speaker 1: OK, so the idea here is basically
the way to fight this incel stuff is you have
to socially show that monogamy is.
Acceptable and lack of monogamy is not, but
it really doesn't actually solve the problem,
even if socially.
Not being monogamous is looked down upon.
It's still not going to help a lot of these
incels.
That's just that's just the reality.
So it's not clear what we do with this type
of information.
But it is clear that the incel factor is a
real enough factor that the Secret Service
threat assessment is to take a term from the
former president looking at it very strongly.
Let me know your thoughts.
You can find me on Twitter
at De Packman.